Can I sit down?
Oh, no, don't sit down.
All right.
Okay.
Oh, my God, it was horrible.
But it was good.
Okay.
For this part, we'll ask you to narrate your own performance.
Watch the video that you just completed.
Verbally describe what you were thinking and feeling at each moment.
Okay?
Speak naturally as if you're explaining it to a friend.
Describe what you remember thinking or feeling at each moment.
Note any moments where you're in particular and those that are otherwise distracted.
Okay.
Describe your experience.
What stood out to you when you were in the zone in particular?
Were there any specific movements or sections that particularly were challenging today?
What was going through your mind during your performance?
What were you thinking about at the end?
Okay.
Start.
So, like, this part leading up when you're, like,
Just keeping my eyes in the front.
This felt pretty normal, like, competition moment.
And then from the first turn, I just had to remind myself it's slippery, so don't go too quickly.
And then after the kick and the double punching, even the blocking motion, I realized that my movements were really small.
And this was completely...
Slower than what I usually do.
Can I pause?
Can I rewind a little bit?
Ah, no.
No? Okay.
So, the moments leading up to, like, the step forward, the punching, and then the block step forward punch, there was a...
I realized my stance was wide.
Stance was wide.
My movements were slower than normal, like, what I normally do because, to be honest, I think I was still...
The body's still waking up.
So, in that sense, like, I knew...
I knew the timing was off.
But there's nothing I can do about it, so I was just trying to think about creating power to offset the timing and to offset the presentation.
After the key up towards the spin, again, I remember that the mats are slippery, so don't overdo it.
Don't go too high to...
To slip or lose the balance for the side kick.
Okay.
Balance for the side kick.
Also trying to remind myself to open the hip by...
By opening the angle of my knee for that side kick.
Elbow...
I wobbled a little bit there.
Wobbled here.
Slipped on the side kick.
So, as you can see, my landing is short and completely off.
Long stance, major deduction there.
This part was okay, but...
In general...
I would say my hand movement...
For the scissor blocks was also very small.
I was pretty tight in movement.
And just...
Slower than usual pace.
Partly, I think, because...
Body isn't at full ideal perf...